If you feel like you're not making
progress, this might be why. In my
earlier part of my career, I read a ton
of self-help books, everything I get my
hands on. But I realized that my life
didn't change. And so this video is
about why that might be the case. And
more importantly, what you can do about
it. If you think about, you know,
climbing a mountain, a lot of people
think that there's like what is the
perfect path up the mountain. But in my
experience, there's usually multiple
paths up the mountain that you can take.
But none of the paths will work if
you're constantly trying to jump from
path to path. Because in the real world,
one path might be direct and might be
steeper. Another path might have more
loops. Now, you might see the other path
and think, "Man, that one's not as
steep." But we don't see about the path
until you get on it. Is that, oh man,
this one's actually going to take me way
longer to get up the mountain. And so,
most of the time, we need perfect
conviction about our plan more than we
need a perfect plan. And so, think of
the paths up the mountain as your
strategy. Like the mission is getting to
the top. That's what we want to do. But
the strategy is how we're going to
prioritize our resources to getting
there. Right? And so your ability to
execute on the path, walk the path,
stick to the path is ultimately the
thing that's going to predicate your
success far more than the path itself,
provided it's sensible. And what I found
in my experience is that most people
actually have a pretty decent idea what
to do. I'll give you a different
analogy. So if I said, "Hey, you need to
get in shape." If you know nothing about
getting in shape, you still probably
have an idea that you should probably
stop eating crap and you should start
moving more. And if you're trying to
gain muscle, you should probably like
lift weights. And if you want to get
bigger, you should probably make those
weights or those reps go up. These are
probably things you'd be like, I kind of
already knew that. But the thing is is
that people don't do that. And so the
issue usually is like, I want to have
this perfect plan. But like, if you just
did only that for the next 3 years,
you'd probably be way better off than
the vast majority of people. And so this
was a big realization that I had, which
is I had this this overanalysis of like
what is the perfect plan? And I call it
the fallacy of the perfect pick, which
is that we wait and we wait to try and
find the perfect p. The thing is is that
this is a $5 million year business
owner. So this is has nothing to do with
where you're at. This happens at all
levels, right? The mountain just gets
bigger. But it's the same concept. And
so for me, there was a period in my life
before I started making, you know, a
more money um where I had nine different
businesses. All right? And I had nine
businesses that I was CEO of and I
wasn't making any money. And we were
making revenue, but because I was so
spread thin thing, I couldn't focus on
any of them enough. And so all I could
do is just barely keep my head above
water. I had, you know, a dental agency,
I had a chiropractic agency. I had my
launch business where I was flying out.
So I was in different cities every week
doing these launches. And then I also
had six locations of gyms that were
running too. So I was so spread, I was
stressed out of my mind. And so most
people can't execute. And so what I
would think at that moment in time like
now looking back it's obvious and maybe
you hearing it's obvious but for some
reason it's kind of like the Yiddish seg
where your nose is an inch above your
mouth but need somebody else to tell you
your breath breath smells bad. I think
it's the same thing with this which is
that at the time if you if I had asked
younger me what do you think the problem
is? I'd be like I think I need to change
my strategy up. I think I need to change
all these things up. When the reality is
that most times you don't need to change
that much at all. You need to actually
just do the one thing really well. And
so it's not about coming up with the
plan or doing the plan. It's sticking
with the plan, right? You can beat most
people at anything if you just stick
with it for a year. If you're willing to
suck at something for a 100 days in a
row, then you can beat most people at
most things. The bar for excellence has
never been so low. And so most of your
competition quits after the first sign
of difficulty, the first impass on the
mountain where they don't immediately
get it because they've never known what
hard feels like. And so you having to
figure something out, the unknown is the
hard part. The figuring it out is the
hard part. And so people think that, oh,
I should switch paths because I
understand the path of getting to here.
So you might get this far up the
mountain and you might be on this path
and think, oh, I could do this path or
this path or this path. The thing is,
usually you have to go back down and
then you got to go over and you got to
go up again, right? So it's actually a
lot longer to keep switching paths. But
we don't think that because this path we
can see. We already walk down here. We
already see the bottom of the mountain.
We can see the path to here. But then
from here, we get stuck again. And so we
keep, you know, releveling up and going
from, you know, level one to level two,
level three really quickly because we've
beaten those bosses before. But then you
get to level four again and you're
stuck. And so you have to grit through
that period where you don't know what
you're doing. And this took me so long
to understand like the not knowing part
is the part that's hard and that is
where people give up. It's not usually
the the like, oh, I just need to work
harder. Sure, there's some people who
are weak and they just lose there, but
most of the times when I talk to
business owners, that's not actually
where they lose. is because they don't
know what to do and so they think, "Oh,
I'll change my strategy rather than
figuring out what to do is the
strategy." And so most strategies do
work. So I want to hit on this a little
harder. One of the misconceptions about
business is that there's this one secret
thing, right? There's usually lots of
ways to win. There's a few ways to skin
a cat, right? If you have a dull knife,
on the other hand, you're never going to
be able to skin the cat. And the
sharpness of your knife is your ability
to execute whatever path you have,
right? Whatever way of skinning cat,
which is actually pretty visceral. and
nasty like who's actually skinning cats
should probably retire that saying I
mean think about a skinned cat it's a
little tough anyways when I was talking
back to the business owner I said okay
so if execution is the issue what's the
that's the okay that's the surface level
problem you're not doing what you know
you should do the underneath of that is
why is this not happening and so I see
this as a combination of two different
things and so one is culture and the
other is talent so I'm going to explain
both in a more operationalized manner so
it's not just these buzzwords all right
so what is culture so culture is the
rules of reinforcement in a business.
Okay. So, what are the things that
govern what gets rewarded and what gets
punished? And so, if you think about
culture, there's probably a hundred or
thousand behaviors that exist within any
business or any environment, right? When
we learn a culture as a society, there
are things that we do. You hold a door.
That's one thing that you do and it gets
rewarded and if you don't do it, it gets
punished, right? If you cut somebody off
in traffic, it gets punished, right? And
so, each of these things are things that
get rewarded or punished. And that's
what creates culture. But within every
business, there's kind of a subculture
within the larger culture where you have
more and more nuance of things that are
your preferences as a business owner.
But if people are not working to your
preferences, then it means the culture
you have, the rules that govern
reinforcement are not being adequately
exercised. And the way that you
reinforce culture is
one, who you hire and who you fire. So
who you allow to exist in the business
tells more to your team about what you
think is acceptable. Number two is the
behavior that you do not allow to
change. So if someone does something
good and you don't reward it, then they
learn that they don't get rewarded for
doing that thing. On the flip side, if
someone shows up 5 minutes late to a
meeting and no one says anything, then
you teach everyone it's okay to be late.
And so the first issue with his business
was that there's probably a culture of
non-performance. And we have to get very
specific with what makes somebody not
perform. And sometimes it's only two or
three behaviors. Often times it's like
20 or 30. And you have to be able to
observe what are the things that makes
me not like my team and what would I
rather them do instead. And so I use the
format of start, stop, keep. So what I
want you to start doing that you're not
doing, what I want you to stop doing
that you are doing, and what do you need
to keep doing that I'm going to keep
reinforcing. It's a very simple way to
give feedback that I really like. Now
what about talent? Because that's the
second half. This is one is the cult is
the rules, right? The talent is the
people who are actually doing the
behaviors, doing the stuff. And so from
a talent perspective, a lot of
businesses can't expand anymore, not
because they uh don't have the model to
do it, but they don't have the ability
to execute on the plan. And the ability
to execute on the plan comes down to the
quality of the people that you have in
the business. And I can tell you this
firsthand, you probably don't have high
enough bar for who should be working for
you. And I say this for myself, too. the
moment I increase the quality of the
people who work with me, the more money
I make, right? And so what's really
interesting is that I think that this is
one of the greatest arbitrage
opportunities that exists in business to
this day still, which is that the 50%
mark for a role is $75,000 a year. Now,
for you to pay 90th percentile, it might
be $115,000 per year. Right now, you
might be like, "Wow, that's a big
difference." But here's the thing is
that this person is probably like five
times more effective than this one, but
they only cost 30% more. That's a great
deal. That's a good investment. And so,
at this point, all I really try and do
is just find rain makers. I want people
who are exceptional, who are obsessed
with this task. Now, how do you
differentiate the people who are good
versus not? I'll give you a tactic
around this. So, when you're
interviewing, I like to know what
someone's doing in their off time. And
if what they do in their off time is not
what I want them to do in their
full-time, then they're not going to be
full-time, right? They're going to be
always moonlighting to their other
thing. And so, I'd rather say like, what
are you obsessed with? And I like asking
that question. What are what are your
extracurricular activities? Now, if
they're like, "Honestly, all I do, let's
say I'm hiring a videographer. They're
like,"All I do is video stuff. Like,
this is what I'm really passionate
about. This is what I spend my time
watching on YouTube is like, "How do I
improve the lighting? How do I improve
the audio? How do I improve the sets?
Like, this is the stuff that I like
really obsessed about." I probably know
that that person's going to do a pretty
good job because also, if I tell them,
"Hey, you need to improve this stuff."
They're like, "Great. I love this
feedback. I want to get better." Now, if
somebody's like, "Oh, I love, you know,
uh, pickle ball and using, you know, and
working out." There's nothing wrong with
that. It's just that is that the thing
that you're obsessed with? And so asking
that question in a couple ways in an
interview will tease out whether someone
is spending their discretionary, effort,
and time on the talent or the skill that
they need to win in their role in the
business. And so that's on the pick
side, right? The third element of this,
uh, here we go, is training. So if you
have rules that govern reinforcement in
the business, okay, this is what we
like, this is what we don't like, and
then you get really good people in, you
still can have people who have potential
versus actual. And so obviously the
higher up in the business, the more
you're hiring for actual, the less
you're hiring for potential. The lower
someone is in the business, the more
you're hiring for potential and less for
actual. And so when we're picking
somebody, it's like I'll pick somebody
who's just generally intelligent and has
work ethic over somebody who might be
more experienced in the career but
doesn't demonstrate the same level of
intelligence because I think the smart
person will be able to catch up to that
dumber person really quickly and then
pass them. And so what does training
look like? And so training in the
business in order to execute, I'm going
to be really clear here. The reason that
your plan isn't working is because no
one's doing the plan. So why aren't they
doing the plan? These are the reasons,
right? And so from a training
perspective, it typically comes down to
observing the details. I'm going to give
you a story about this. So I was meeting
with a different business which is a
solar sales company that was doing, you
know, multiple figures, which is great,
goodiz business. And the founder was
telling me that they were struggling to
develop a sales leadership within the
business. And he said they did an
off-site and they came up with like
their six pillars of sales leadership.
And it was like accountability, time
management, blah blah blah blah, right?
They had like six things. I don't
remember where they were. And he said
after the two-day, you know, two-day
event where everyone came together and
agreed on those principles, they went
back and no one changed their behavior.
And I said, "Okay, well, what does
accountability mean in terms of
behavior? What is like, show me what
someone who's holding someone
accountable does? How would I know that
accountability had occurred?" Right? And
so what happens there's he was like wait
so I need to be like oh you need to text
your team every morning and you have to
do end of week reports with every person
review and you need to at the end of the
day give kudos to the people who did
well and then ask the people who didn't
do well what they were struggling with
and then drill them on how to improve
that skill. He's like oh I was like
right say that. Don't say
accountability. No one knows what it
means. We have to translate these big
words into smaller actions that we want
someone to make. And then it's very easy
to say, "Hey, you didn't do these four
things rather than," you didn't hold
someone accountable because they're
like, "I don't know. I thought I was
holding him accountable." Because we
both have different definitions for the
same thing. And if this sounds more
nuanced, guess what? Welcome to
business. Right? These are skills that
you just need to develop at some point
because changing strategy forever over
and over again is never going to get you
up the mountain. All you're going to do
is keep going down from this one over to
this one and then maybe you get to here
and then you change over and then you go
over to here. And so each time you're
wasting all of the extra effort keeping
switching paths rather than saying, "Oh,
the issue I have is talent, which means
I need to recruit better. Oh, the issue
is culture, which means that I have to
show my leaders how to punish and reward
behavior in the business. Oh, we're
getting people in, but they're not being
productive. So, we need to improve our
training rather than just say, "Oh,
everyone sucks." Right? And so a lot of
success comes to sticking with something
long enough to make the number of
mistakes required to actually figure it
out. Otherwise, you just keep starting
from zero every single month. And you
can beat 99% of people without being
smarter or luckier, but by being willing
to endure pain and uncertainty for
longer. That's the path up the mountain.
Hey guys, real quick. If you want to
have a blueprint of how to get up the
mountain, um this is the free 100
million scaling road map, the zillion
dollar scaling road map. Um, this is
something that was actually an internal
tool that we made for ourselves so we
could better identify at every level of
scaling what a company would probably
have to work on in order to get to the
next level. And then we just decided to
make it free. And so if you want this,
you go to
acquisition.com/roadmap and you can
enter business information and grab it.
And if you like my team to give you
personalized tactics that on the next
page, you can book a call. We'll get to
know you, get to know the business, and
ultimately invite you out if it makes
sense. And at that point, we'd actually
meet with you in person and say, "Hey,
these are the things that we think are
going to be the unlocks for your
business right now. These are the things
that can help pay down the uncertainty
on the path you're already on." So, hey,
just look around the edge, you know,
just here's a drill bit so you can get
through the rock, right? Rather than
say, "Oh, we have to reinvent the
business." Because most time we just
need to do what we're doing a little
better, a little different. And by doing
that, it unlocks the path of the
mountain so you can see it. So, click
the link and uh maybe I'll see you here
in